واصل معارضوا اصلاح نظام التقاعد في فرنسا
التعبير عن غضبهم وسط توجه الى اغلاق
مصافي التكرير وقال متحدث باسم شركه توتال
الفرنسيه للطاقه ان 34% من العمال
التشغيليين بالمصافي
والمستودعات اضربوا عن العمل تزامنا مع
استمرار الاحتجاجات على خطط الحكومه لرفع
سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
واعلنت الكونفدراليه العامه للعمل ان اكبر
مصفاه في البلاد والتي تقع في النورمانجي
بشمال غرب فرنسا بدات بالتوقف عن العمل
لكن لا يتوقع ان تسبب نقصا فوريا في
الوقود في المحطات الفرنسيه
وقد تتخذ الحكومه اجراءات في حال اغلاق
هذه المنشات لتجنب نقص الوقود وفق وزير
الصناعه الفرنسيه
ومع مواصله معارضي اصلاح نظام التقاعد في
فرنسا التعبير عن غضبهم في مسيرات جديده
تراجعت شعبيه رئيس
بشكل كبير في مارس الى 28 بالمئه وهي
الادنى منذ نهايه ازمه السترات الصفر عام
وبحسب استطلاع النشرته صحيفه لجورنالدو
الفرنسيه شملت الفا
1928 شخصا فان 70% من المستطلعين غير
راضين عن اداء ماكرون
الى باريس الان ومزيد من المتابع مع مراسل
العربيه فادي دهوك فادي اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد المشهد من عندك في هذه الاوقات مع
العلم ان اليوم هو يوم عطله يوم الاحد في
فرنسا
اهلا طالب نعم اليوم هو يوم عطله في فرنسا
لكن هناك تظاهره خرجت قبل قليل في احدى
المراكز التجاريه في ضاحيه ساندوني هذه
التظاهرات تخرج متى تخرج بشكل مفاجئ وهي
سريعه جدا يخرجون في مراكز للتسوق وايضا
في الشوارع حتى الان هنا في ساحه
الكونكورد على مقربه من البرلمان كما ترون
هناك حشد امني لحراسه هذه المنطقه هي تقع
في المربع الامني للعاصمه باريس تحسبا من
خروج التظاهرات طبعا الشرطه قامت بتمديد
حظر التظاهر في هذه المنطقه اليوم بعدما
اصدرت قرار حظر التظاهرات في هذه الساحه
يوم امس ايضا هذه الساحه شهدت مواجهات
عنيفه جدا على مدار يومين منذ يوم الخميس
الماضي وهو الموعد الذي استخدمت فيه
الحكومه الماده
49,3 لتمرير مشروع قانون رفع سن التقاعد
وهنا في الساحه نرى عبارات كثيره واثار
للمتظاهرين تركوها مثل هذه اللا كتبوا
عليها 49.3 كيلومتر في الساعه في اشاره
الى ان هذه المساله اصبحت عاصفه ستكون ضد
الحكومه في اطار الاحتجاجات طبعا هناك
ايضا مساله الاضرابات التي تحدثت عنها في
مستودعات تكرير النفط هناك عدد من
المستودعات بدات تفكر في ان تقوم باجراء
اضرابها ابتداء من يوم الاثنين واحد
الثلاثاء المقبل سيستمر هذا الاضراب
ليومين لكن حتى الان لم يتخذ القرار بعد
ايضا هناك مساله اضراب المعلمين يوم غد
سيكون اليوم الاول في امتحانات الثانويه
العامه وهناك حاله من عدم اليقين ما اذا
كان المراقبون سوف يتوجهون لمراقبه هذه
الامتحانات بالاضافه الى ان عدد كبير من
المنظمات الطلابيه يدعون الى اغلاق
الثانويات ومنع تقديم الامتحانات فيها
ايضا هل يمكن القول ان الايام المقبله
ستشهد مزيدا من التازم والتصعيد في الشارع
ام لا الحكومه تراهن على الوقت انه مع
الوقت النقبات والاتحاد العماليه ستنصاع
لهذا القرار عاجلا ام اجلا
الحكومه تراهن على مساله الوقت لكن هذا
الاسبوع سيكون حاسما جدا ابتداء من يوم
الغد سوف يكون هناك تصويت في البرلمان على
مذكره لحجب الثقه من الحكومه الفرنسيه هذه
المذكره او هم طرحت مذكرتين واحده من قوى
اقصى اليمين بزعابه مارينلوبين والاخرى من
كتله النواب المستقلين ستدعمها كل الاحزاب
السياسيه وايضا ابدت كتله مارين لوبين
استعدادها للتصويت عليها لذا المشهد ما
يزال متوترا وهناك ترقب كبير ايضا سيكون
هناك يوم تعبئه وطني في فرنسا في الثالث
والعشرين من هذا الشهر سيكون يوما للاضراب
والتظاهر تنظمه النقابات والاحزاب
اليساريه وايضا قد تنضم اليه الحركه
الطلابيه التي بدات او هي التي تقوم بهذا
الحراك منذ ثلاثه ايام وتخوض مواجهات
عنيفه مع الشرطه يوم امس كان هناك تظاهرات
كبيره في العاصمه باريس واسفرت عن اعتقال
110 اشخاص بحسب ما اعلنت وزاره الداخليه
في تحديث جديد للارقام اليوم هذه
التظاهرات بدات تخرج في معظم المدن
الفرنسيه وايضا في مناطق صغيره جدا ونائيه
الكل يتظاهر ضد هذا القانون والمشهد متوتر
وفي تراقب شديد في العاصمه من باريس مراسل
العربيه فادي دهوك شكرا جزيلا لك فادي على
هذه المشاركه